oh it caught me lounging on my purple
Velveteen sofa in the heart of Manhattan
when you get a TV show this is what your
life looks like hey guys I'm in New York
City right now I'm here to do a bunch of
press for the grace Helbig show
premiering on e on Friday April 3rd at
10:30 p.m. following the soup I got here
and the big thing is tomorrow I'm going
to be on Jimmy Fallon my poo pourri
spilled all over my toiletries
everything smells like orange blossoms
which is now what I associate with smell
of shakes that use poo pourri so much so
now to me everything that I own smells
like I think that's a good sign
I'm a little tired from travel so I
thought today we're just gonna do a very
pure and simple
Q&A I wonder my facebook page and at you
guys for questions so if you don't like
my Facebook page shoo and second of all
you miss out on great opportunities like
this like being able to ask me a
question that I probably won't answer
also the grace Helbig show has done
Facebook page which you should go over
and look at because we're putting up all
sorts of extra content over there and
behind the scenes stuff it's going to be
really really fun also the gray zombie
show has a Twitter handle right show the
hashtag for the show is going to be
great show and the Facebook page is
going show so well that's a great show
it's losing all meaning already let's
get into your questions what do you miss
the most about a OTS for those of you
that don't know a OTS stands for attack
of the show was a show on g4 about video
gaming and the internet and pop culture
and I got to do some stuff on it and it
was so so fun unfortunately doesn't
exist anymore but I think the thing I
miss the most about it is seeing the
antiquarian thinking a really angry
dyslexic really needs boats and isn't
able to express themselves how do I deal
with the fear of entering the real world
after I graduate this summer balance it
with a gratitude you should have about
entering the real world and not the real
world on MTV expected this to be the ton
of our
what three words would you use to
describe how you feel about the grace
Helbig project excited it's terrified
overwhelmed causing me to forget what
the number three is but optimistic three
how useless is my arts degree I was
going to show you some art that was in
this hotel room make you feel bad about
your arts degree but there's no art in
this hotel room so you should feel
really bad art is dying
Velvets where it's at now why does the
Easter Bunny carry eggs I don't know I
was thinking about Easter the other day
wondering when it was and then thinking
about it as a holiday and what the it's
a rabbit that comes to your house that
leaves you a basket of eggs where did
the rabbit get the eggs does the rabbit
ask permission why do kids need the eggs
creativity is wonderful and terrible put
fifth Army on your show you've got it
Isabella
Romero I will say oh if I say it it gets
done how TV works there are no other
people that need to approve anything or
be involved at all whatsoever
fifth harmony doesn't even get to a
proof they want to be on the show put
fifth harmony on the show not even a
question a statement why I chose to even
acknowledge it in this video
questionable now secretly I wish that
this was like a fake account for the CEO
of the e network and they were going to
make some suggestions for the show via
my facebook Q&A am i Celine Dion this
question maybe we laugh so much because
I just imagine you tripping on mushrooms
by yourself sincerely wondering if
you're silly
Dion and no they're not Celine and I am
not today but we all wish that we were
with me oh god sorry guys my battery
died right when I was trying to explain
to you that none of us can ever be on an
A it does if Rene has some superhuman
universe powers and could tell that I
was mentioning him in some way he just
shut it down he took all of the life out
of my battery what are your opinions
marching band in color guard
Masumi what are my opinions on marching
band in color guard I think you guys are
very horny go-getters you're very
enthusiastic about extracurriculars and
trombone errs what is your favorite
brand of tampons ones that work wouldn't
it be fun to name a brand of tampons
Grey Poupon gzm do you have any Grey
Poupon no it wouldn't be fun to be awful
terrible awful awful idea part of my
mission on earth is to say awful ideas
out loud
so you never have to say them out loud
for the first time in front of people
and possibly embarrass yourself you're
welcome Grey Poupon also great child's
name in 2016 watch out can you be
serious for five seconds course
I camp heyyyyy you gave this thing a
television show all right that's all the
questions I'm going to get to today
thank you guys for leaving them for me
to answer in a way that was hopefully
fun for you and not just the worst
goddamn thing in the whole world make
sure you guys tune in to Jimmy Fallon
tonight because I'm going to be honest
cat it's like Renee is trying to make me
stop making this video I get it Renee
I'll never talk about you again I don't
know are you still going to be making
videos as much when your show starts
there at Izzy Lizzie Lizzie Lizzie don't
you worry your beautiful little face no
touching I get it I get it
don't you worry your beautiful beautiful
face I will be making web videos all
throughout the show and if you go to the
gray show Facebook page there's gonna be
all sorts of extra video content up
there I'm gonna put some extra content
on my YouTube channel related to the
show and guys it's just gonna be you
might be so ill of my face because
there's gonna be a lot going on in the
next couple weeks I might be one ill
grace you could have been running myself
ragged run yourself ragged the grace
Helbig Nicki campaign